Hi everyone, this is Jerry.
This is a game from the 1972 World Chess Championship
between Bobby Fischer and Boris Spassky.
It's a Round 10 game, Fischer had the white
pieces and opened with e4, "best by test"
as he would say.
Spassky plays e5, knight f3, knight c6, and
bishop to b5.
So this indicates the Ruy Lopez or Spanish
game.
Pressure on the knight, indirect pressure
on the pawn.
I'll just be showing some alternative variations.
There is a lot to know with the Ruy Lopez,
there is a lot of theory on it.
I'll just be touching on some what-ifs.
In the game we saw a6, but what if knight
f6?
Pressure against e4.
We could see white simply castling and black
opting to go for the Berlin Defense, grabbing
on e4 and the following sequence of moves
coming about where the end result looking
on the black side and black's deficiencies,
is that the black king is uncastled and has
a little messed up pawn structure, but as
compensation has the bishop pair in an open
position which is usually an asset.
So that's a little trade-off that would occur
from that position.
But we don't see that, but instead a6 chases
the bishop back to a4.
One other quick note, if you try to grab this
pawn like this, queen d4 is played, these
two are hit, the pawn will be regained.
So that's why we see bishop back.
And now knight f6, hitting e4.
White simply ignores that threat and castles
in this game.
Bishop e7 was played.
But again what if knight takes pawn?
This indicates the Tarrasch variation.
Can this pawn be taken for free without black
getting killed?
Well, the answer is no but you have to know
how to react to that sort of move.
d4 to just try and open up this position at
a moment where white is ahead in development
and the black king has yet to castle.
This e-file is really going to come into play
in this sort of variation.
b5, bishop b3, and now an important point
in this position as black.
You can't be greedy, you can't just go ahead
and grab pawns like this.
That'll be met with rook e1 and you are in
an uncomfortable pin.
How to really meet this threat against your
knight which is unprotected and pinned?
d5 can be met sharply with knight c3, and
if you grab my knight, I'm going to grab the
pawn, and for those of you who are jujitsu
fans you'll know that black from this position
will be "tapping out" very shortly.
These two knights are hit directly, this rook
is hit indirectly all by just one white piece,
and this knight is really just doomed.
He's really caught in a crossfire, hit by
both the bishop and rook.
So it's just bad news for black from this
position, not to be recommended going into
this specific variation.
However from this point right here instead
of taking the pawn we could see simply d5,
a much better response opting to allow the
bishop to come to this e6 square as well as
allow this pawn to support this e4 knight.
After pawn takes pawn, just to summarize it
very briefly: the material has been restored
and it's just a much more playable position
for sure.
We don't see this, we don't see the Tarrasch
variation but instead black opts for bishop
to e7, more development.
And it is at this point that black is maybe
getting ready to really grab that pawn and
hang onto it.
So only at this point here does white choose
to go ahead and defend this pawn.
What's interesting to note is that there are
other ways to go ahead and watch over e4.
You could play d3, watches over e4, you could
play knight c3.
Both of these outlined moves that I have in
blue watch this over e4 pawn, so why aren't
they played?
In the Ruy Lopez, it's important for you to
know what sort of plan to implement, what
sort of middle game strategy should you try
to undertake.
Knowing this thing will allow you to know
why rook to e1 is the preferred move from
such a position.
Here is what you want to do as white: you
want to make a move like pawn to c3, followed
by pawn to d4.
You want to establish two pawns in the center
on these two specific squares and "maintain"
them on those two squares for as long as you
can.
And I emphasize "maintain" for a very important
reason which I will get to later.
c3 is played for a couple reasons, again to
support this d4 advance as well as provide
a cubbyhole for this bishop on the c2 square.
And taking that into account...
if that's what we want to do, it stands to
reason that that's why we shouldn't make a
move like knight to c3, because we want to
have our pawn here, and we don't play pawn
to d3 because we don't want this pawn to play
the role of a defensive piece.
Its aspirations are to get to d4 where it
is an aggressive piece putting pressure on
this e5 pawn.
So with that in mind, that's why we're seeing
the move rook to e1.
One additional benefit of this rook move to
e1 is that f1 is vacated so that this sort
of knight type of maneuver is possible.
It's often the case that in this opening the
position will close up, and when that occurs,
maneuvering type of moves just in general
are more likely to occur.
And so you could see the knight take this
sort of journey where it starts on b1 of course
and it ends up on g3 with its ideal square
focusing on this f5 point, a soft point in
the black position.
So those are some things to be aware of.
This is why we are playing rook here because
we want to take into account what white's
plan is going to be and we're also vacating
f1 for our b1 knight.
At this point white is actually getting ready
to go ahead and chop on c6 and then on e5
and simply be up pawn.
If black castles at this point we could just
go ahead and go for this.
And notice how this move here, queen d4 it's
not the same.
White has clearly done some more development
prior to grabbing the pawn.
There is no queen takes pawn from this variation
the rook is of course watching over it.
So after rook to e1, now we see this pawn
to b5 move chasing the bishop to b3.
And now black opts to play d6.
What's interesting to me is why d6 is played
here opposed to just castling.
Castling will allow black to at least consider
going into the Marshall Attack.
For example: if c3 is played here black could,
you know if you are an aggressive player as
black you could be making this pawn to d5
move, giving up pawn in exchange for pressure
against the white king.
These are the moves that you would see played:
c6, a move like bishop d6, the queen could
jet out to h4 to try and induce some pawn
move for white...
try to induce some sort of pawn advance which
creates a weakness against a white king who
is lacking defensive pieces.
More specifically, look at the queen side,
just take a quick glance, none of them have
been moved.
So white is lagging in development.
So that's really where a lot of the compensation
lies from such a variation.
We're not seeing this but again that's just
something that kind of interests me here after
bishop b3... why not just simply castle and
at least reserve the option to play d6 or
d5.
But nevertheless what we see is just d6 here,
and now c3 and only then castle.
So keeping in mind what we want to do, we
want to play this d4 move, however we don't
want to play it just yet, and there is a big
reason why.
If we play d4 right now, what black can do
is play bishop g4.
And the word that I was previously emphasizing
is this word "maintained".
Not only do we want to establish two pawns
on d4 and e4 but we want to be able to maintain
them there for as long as we can.
There is a big reason for this, and it's because
this pawn on d4 is the one who could really
change the pawn structure whenever it wants.
It could capture on e5 or it could push forward.
Or let me just back up... after bishop g4
it could capture on e5 and open up the position,
or it could opt to play d5 and close up the
position.
Being in that sort of set up where you have
the option to really change the pawn structure...
to open the position up, or to close the position
really makes a big deal.
Because for as long as you keep black guessing
what you're going to do, it's very difficult
for black to meet those sorts of ideas.
You know, will white open up the position
or is white going to close up the position?
We really want to keep black guessing for
as long as we can.
But if we play d4 right away like this, bishop
g4 will do what's referred to as "resolve
this tension in the center".
This tension cannot be maintained because
of the pressure that's now being placed on
the white position.
More specifically this knight on f3 is a critical
defender of this d4 square, and with this
bishop not only getting ready to take this
knight... for example let me just play a nothing
type of move if a3 is played, if bishop takes
knight we can't recapture with the queen because
we're going to lose on d4, and if we capture
like this well notice how we've weakened our
own king side structure.
So in other words, it's important to insert
this move right here for white, instead of
d4 right away, we want to play h3 to prevent
this bishop from coming here because again,
not only do we want to establish pawns here
in the center, but we want to maintain them
there for as long as we can.
So, knight b8 seems a bit awkward.
That goes into what's known as the Breyer
variation, knight to b8.
It's intention is to reposition itself on
this d7 square, have the knights connected
and also it allows for this c5 advance.
So notice for as long as the knight is on
c6 this pawn can of course not move at all.
So the knight move allows this pawn on c7
to advance where it could then meet this,
you know challenge this pawn that white is
going to be placing on d4 very soon.
One other variation, black and go for knight
a5, and bishop here followed by c5.
We could see d4, queen c7.
This is another way to go about things.
But we are not seeing that.
Instead the Breyer variation, knight b8 followed
by knight b to d7 will be in effect.
And only now d4, so finally we've made all
the prep moves necessary, c3, h3, and only
now d4.
Knight b to d7, essentially a developing move
right...
underdeveloped and now we have to get it back
into play.
Knight b to d2 and bishop to b7.
Notice how by putting pressure immediately
on this point right here, black is restraining
this d2 knight.
I was mentioning earlier that this knight
would like to get to f1, maybe g3.
But we can't do that just yet, that pawn will
fall.
So by putting pressure on the white center,
we stop this sort of maneuver.
Bishop back to c2, lends a supporter of this
e4 point and also allows this pawn to come
to b4.
White is anticipating that black will be playing
c5.
So white wants to get this b-pawn involved
in the fight for control of the center.
Rook e8 getting ready to tuck the bishop here
where the rook would then add potential pressure
against this e4 pawn.
b4, bishop back allows again the rook to see
this pawn here, and now we see a4.
Again a move like knight to f1 can't be played
because after capture, this pawn is hit three
times and will be won next.
So knight to f1 is out.
Instead we see pawn to a4, striking at this
pawn.
This rook pawn is hitting a knight pawn, and
this a-file can potentially open up on white's
terms.
Knight b6 looks to resolve this tension, and
Fischer opts to simply play a5.
One other alternative, you know white can
go ahead and capture like this but I think
black would be the side that's in a better
position to cope with the tension that is
now going on between these two rooks.
Black can simply maybe make a move like queen
d7, and then the rooks would be in direct
contact with one another.
For example: bishop b2, queen here.
These rooks are in direct contact with one
another.
The white queen is interfering with these
rooks for the moment.
And you may very well see maybe a move like
knight to a4 causing maybe white some problems
since it would be hitting this bishop and
pawn right here.
You may very well see white having to give
this bishop up for the knight.
So that's why we're maybe not seeing this
pawn exchange right here in this position,
but instead a5.
If the knight goes here that'll just run into
the loss of a pawn.
So a5 kicks the knight back to d7.
It may seem insignificant but the knight coming
to b6, a5, and then the knight going back
to d7.
Its main purpose was just to resolve the tension
that was going on between those two pawns.
Bishop b2 gets the last minor piece involved,
and it looks a little bit awkwardly placed
because it's just staring at its own pawn.
But in anticipation of this advance here,
soon enough this bishop will be able to see
the black position a little bit more clearly.
So queen b8 an interesting move.
What's its intention?
To watch over this e5 pawn in a very indirect
way.
There's some more work that needs to be done
before the queen is watching over e5 directly.
This pawn will have to move, this pawn on
d6 will have to move, but this is the idea
that's in mind with this queen b8 maneuver.
Rook to b1, a little bit of an awkward move.
What is its purpose?
To watch over this bishop in anticipation
of what black will be wanting to do.
What does black want to do in this position?
He wants to get this c7 pawn involved.
If black doesn't make that sort of move, what
more really is there in the position.
So what we do see is c5.
We have a series of exchanges, and soon enough
this bishop which looked dumb on b2 springs
to life.
We have a bunch of exchanges going on on e5.
After the queen recaptures, pawn to c4.
So what was the purpose of rook b1?
Watch over this bishop so it's protected and
this c4 move could come about.
The queen is now hit.
Queen f4, and now the bishop simply grabs
this knight.
I'm not sure what else could be played here.
If pawn takes pawn, that could run into some
trouble with maybe this sort of pin.
The knight is hit once.
Maybe there is this pin going on.
Right?
How to really meet that threat, and maybe
this knight could grab here on the next turn.
So that's why we're not seeing that sort of
capture go on, pawn takes pawn because of
the pressure that could be placed on this
d2 knight.
Instead bishop takes knight, queen takes bishop,
and only now pawn takes pawn.
And rook on e to d8, a very sharp move looking
to, well first and foremost placing the knight
in a pin, but black is now getting ready to
place this queen very deep in the white position
where she really radiates, really shows herself
quite well hitting this knight again and also
hitting this a5 pawn.
So white simply gets out of that pin right
away, and queen c3 hits this knight for a
second time.
We can play this nice regrouping type of move,
moving to its most natural square a classical
square on f3.
And after queen takes pawn we see bishop to
b3.
This is an interesting move, you know with
this tension between these two pawns you may
very well be tempted as white to maybe just
grab this pawn here but Fischer is starting
to look at this king here and how this point
on f7, this pawn on f7 is a bit vulnerable.
If you could attack it once and maybe a second
time that starts to be an issue and sure enough
in this game pressure starts to mount against
this pawn right here on f7.
So let's start out first with bishop b3, places
that pawn in a pin, and after pawn takes pawn
we have queen to f4.
So this pawn is hit twice, some calculation
was of course needed with this sequence of
moves bishop b3, queen f4.
What calculation exactly?
Well you have to know how to cope with this
move here of course.
Normally if there weren't any tactics in this
position, this c4 move would just slam a door
in this bishop's face.
But we could just capture like this and then
the rook is there to just come to the seventh
rank and cause some more problems for black.
Queen f4 is played, this move is out of the
question and now we have rook d7 adding a
supporter.
Knight e5 attacking the rook and the pawn.
So we are just piling up on f7 at this point.
The queen comes back to defend f7 indirectly
and place the knight in a pin against the
queen.
And now we have rook b to d1.
This is a very important point in the game.
We can't just make any rook move.
This rook on e1 is contributing in some way
to the position; it's watching over e4.
This rook, it's only intention previously
was to watch over a bishop that was on b2.
It has finished its duty in doing that, so
it's time to get that rook involved.
That's why we're seeing rook b to d1.
And after rook to e7, we have a series of
exchanges occurring on f7, and we quickly
arrive at an endgame position which is unbalanced.
We have these two pawns which are together.
They are connected passed pawns.
And we end up having an unbalanced position
where Fischer is able to show some really
good technique in bringing the point home.
Bishop takes pawn, rook takes bishop, so a
series of exchanges, and at this point bishop
takes pawn here.
If king takes knight, we just have rook check
and grab the bishop.
So taking on e4 first will allow black to
gain additional material prior to grabbing
on f7.
So bishop takes, rook takes, king takes and
now rook on the seventh giving a check, and
king to f6.
So essentially what you want to do as white
in this position is restrain these guys from
pressing forward.
So ideally the rook came here not to just
check, but it really wants to get to this
b7 square.
It wants to get behind these pawns to prevent
them from pressing forward.
So rook b7, rook check, king h2, bishop d6
check, g3, and now b4.
So finally the threat rook takes b5 was met.
And now what do we do with the endgame?
We get our kings involved, king g2.
h5, I'm not quite sure what that does.
Maybe just prevents this g4 move from coming
about.
It's really difficult to suggest good moves
for black in this position because these white
rooks are placed very well.
They are really stopping the black pawns from
advancing.
Neither move could come about without the
loss of material for black.
So just rook b6 really just trying to tie
black up as best you can.
The bishop is now pinned so the rook moves
there to defend.
King f3, king back to get out of the pin,
king e2.
This rook is lacking squares.
It really could only go to d5 to still be
in direct contact with the bishop, and f4.
We have a three versus two majority.
So we have to get these three pawns rolling,
so that's why we're seeing this advancement
f4.
We are going to see g4 as well.
In the meantime what can black do?
Not a whole lot, in fact this rook right here
doesn't have any reasonable moves.
Any moves would result in the loss of material.
So black has to resort to this sort of pawn
move.
Black is very close to just being in zugzwang.
I guess there could be a move like bishop
back here but really nothing concrete is coming
about with the black moves here.
So g6, g4, we have the exchange of pawns,
and now g5 looking to just grab the last of
the white pawns.
Maybe after something like this, maybe if
black could grab this pawn here at some point.
Of course this bishop is hanging but ideally
what black would like to do in this position
is really just trade all of the white pawns
and just get into an ending where it's the
rook and bishop versus the two white rooks.
That's a much more drawable sort of position.
So in response to g5, Fischer wants to maintain
those pawns on the board so that's why we
see f5.
Bishop to e5 preventing this rook from maybe
making use of e6.
In fact there could very well be threats like
rook b7, and if the king comes here that would
actually run into mate with rook to e6.
So the bishop to e5 move stops the rook from
accessing these squares here.
So rook b5 pins this pawn to the rook which
allows this move right here rook takes pawn.
And black is pretty much in a bind right here.
The move played was king to f6, allowing rook
takes pawn.
But there really wasn't a way to avoid it.
For example if you move this bishop, we could
see rook check, king here.
That's really the only move right?
Because if you go here you get mated and if
you go here you get mated.
So this is the only move from this position.
And actually what we would see from here is
a move like king to d3.
Notice how we don't have to worry about this
discovered check.
The bishop can go wherever it wants.
We have all our pieces on light squares.
This guy is not going to bother us at all.
So the king can kind of just shift over and
alleviate this rook's duty of watching over
this pawn from advancing.
So this king can come to c2 and watch over
this pawns advancement.
And in the meantime this rook could eventually
come over in this direction and maybe threaten
to come here at some point, maybe get ready
to press forward on f6.
So things like that are in the air if black
isn't careful.
So considering those sorts of ideas that white
has, black is opting to just allow this sort
of capture to occur.
So king f6, rook grabs the pawn and now bishop
to d4.
Grabbing the rook going into this endgame
is simply lost.
Pawn here, rook here, pawn here, and the king
is just going to sneak over here and just
grab this pawn next.
These two pawns right here are connected.
So it's a big asset in almost all pawn endings.
This ending right here would be no exception.
So we don't see that sort of exchange after
rook pawn, simply bishop d4.
White throws in a check here, king to e5,
and now a sharp move right here by Fischer,
king to f3 threatening mate.
There is no time to grab this rook because
of rook e6.
So how to meet that?
The rook simply retreats allowing the king
to make use of d5 in the event of a check.
And now white offers these rook exchanges.
This is a good strategy... if you are up material,
offer some exchanges.
So that's what we have with this sequence
of moves.
And once these rooks are on this position
right here, now we have this possibility where
the rook can come to g6, getting ready to
grab him and then it's just going to be bad
news for black.
So finishing up we have king d5, the rook
grabs the pawn, bishop e5, f6 pins the bishop
to the king.
And after king to d4, we have rook to b1.
And from this position black resigns, and
for good reason.
How to really meet this threat right here
where the rook is getting ready to just check
the king and then grab the rook?
There is really no convenient way to do it
because this king unfortunately from this
position is tied down to having to defend
this bishop here.
So if something like this occurs...
just showing you one variation if bishop takes
pawn, we could simply see, really just pick
your favorite variation, this would be one
of them: rook check, king here.
We could just simply grab this pawn and then
grab this rook, and this is going to be a
won game.
So as it went in this game, after king to
d4 and rook to b1, Spassky ends up resigning.
So that's all for this video.
Hope you are able to take something away from
it.
Take care, bye.